regardez
[Musique]
pourquoi bannir jours
la mise à jour
c'est comme si tu dis non bout vêtu à
traves ici comme si tu attrapes et une
logiciel
[Musique]
m
il ya une personne qui m'a envoyé un
message en privé en disant merci
beaucoup je serai présente donc à cette
journée de marathon je vais essayer de
d'y participer et tous et merci de
continuer à nous faire vivre un peu et
ce mot là nous faire vivre un peu je me
suis dit waouh
mais c'est tellement fort c'est parce
que voilà la détresse des gens est
tellement réel que à un moment comme ça
ou peut-être les gens ils vont pouvoir
respirer de 10h à 21h ils vont pouvoir
danser découvrir des claquettes du
hacking avec moi du hip hop c'est quand
même assez extraordinaire est assez
assez ouais on se sent privilégié et
j'avais vraiment envie de faire partie
[Musique]
franchement je me suis signé mais quel
talent quoi avec
avec leurs deux aces c'est hyper riches
en avaient plein les yeux plein la tête
ouais j'avais des étoiles dans les yeux
sur sur quasiment fait toutes les vidéos
quoi quand même parce que c'était
vraiment beau on était à fond pendant
une demi heure
et puis on pouvait passer une perf après
est juste à être spectateur et ça
c'était vraiment chouette
donc ouais ça fait celui du bien et ça
fait toujours du bien de la danse trop
bien
[Musique]
yeah vous allez donner un cours de l'or
j'en suis sorti épuisé mais extrêmement
heureux parce que au-delà des de
l'argent qu'on a récolté on est mis en
lumière d'un des artistes son milieu en
lumière des lieux culturels et on a mis
en lumière une cause et tout ça a porté
ses fruits donc je suis épuisé mais
heureux d'encouragement sur la
bienveillance on commentaire après
effectivement il ya tout un côté humain
qui me manque énormément qui sont tout
simplement les applaudissements et
l'énergie d'une salle parce que c'était
magique ce qui se passe est vraiment
dans une salle de spectacle moi je le
compare pour les gens qui comprennent
rien à la culture ou qui font semblant
ne pas comprendre la culture se compare
à un match de foot quand tout le monde
se tait dans le stade et que on regarde
ce qu'il va se passer parce qu'on est à
deux doigts de marquer le but c'est ça
qui se passe dans un théâtre quand quand
il ya un moment de grâce au camp tient
un moment merveilleux qui est en train
de se tasser devant nos yeux
c'est ce moment là moi qui me manque
énormément
le contact avec le public c'est toutes
ces petites actions qui nous permettent
de garder de capitaliser et de
d'échangés toujours avec et j'ai hâte de
retourner dans mon
dans mon terrain de jeu à moi pour le
faire
[Musique]